I say you know me when a bit of movie
news comes out it's about a movie that
I'm really pumped about I got to talking
about those news especially when it's
news like this and the news is The
Hobbit is officially not going to be two
movies but it's gonna be three it's
gonna be a trilogy and today I say I'll
be honest I'm a bit torn about this news
no matter what happens he's gonna take
artistic license and some liberties and
some of the stuff that happens in The
Hobbit he did with Lord of the Rings
turns out Lord of the Rings is a
completely epic and awesome movie I'll
review it eventually but what concerns
me about the news that it's now going to
be a trilogy is that he went into
production and filmed the movies
thinking all right is gonna be two
movies and the story goes he cut
together the first movie The Hobbit and
unexpected journey and he was like
alright that's done he's cutting
together the second movie and he's like
there's a lot more I want to tell I
should probably make it three movies and
if that's the case I'm like okay I mean
yeah I'm still concerned I feel like I'm
gonna be watching The Hobbit it's gonna
be like 'hot meanwhile and Mordor
there's gonna be scenes where you're
like that was shoehorned in let me guess
that was a scene here II film so we can
make it three movies I don't want to
watch this movie with the feeling of
yeah this is clearly supposed to be two
movies now it's three and he has good
intentions and ideas around making in a
trilogy he's like I want to show this I
want to show this I want to show this if
it make it just to movies I can't show
all that I want to show more of the
history of middle-earth from my
understanding Peter Jackson's pulling
from middle-earth lore that's not going
against Canon Middle Earth's huge it has
a lot of history it has a lot of lore so
you know he's like I can incorporate
some of this stuff in The Hobbit make it
a bit more of a full experience you know
an experience of middle-earth not just
one story about one dude and when you
hear what he wants to do you can't help
but be like I want to see that like the
rise of the necromancer I don't know how
they're gonna do it but I want to say it
and if he's going to make the Hobbit a
trilogy to show us more of that stuff
I'm actually down with that as long as
it fits I mean this being a new line and
Warner Brothers maybe you can't help but
think that Warner Brothers was like oh
yeah we no longer have the Christopher
Nolan Dark Knight movies those are done
if we no longer have Harry Potter that
franchise is done can you make it three
movies please so you can see why I'm
kind of divided about this if Peter
Jackson is doing it because he truly
believes that this is the best way to
tell the story
awesome I'm down with it I just want the
Hobbit to be the best version of The
Hobbit it can be if that means one movie
if that means 12 movies so be it it
won't mean 12 movies but you get my
point if this is happening so astute
you know gets more money that's just
irritating it's irritating and it's not
gonna lead to a better product that's
just a fact
but so far Peter Jackson has proven at
least with Lord of the Rings that he's
the kind of guy who's like hate dude all
right
do I know what I'm doing did you see
Lord of the Rings did you like it then I
clearly know what I'm doing trust me and
alright I'll give him the benefit of the
doubt he's proven himself to be an
artist who has a vision and he knows
what he's doing
won't let the sins of other directors
and producers make me think that he's a
dick now but this is just for a cash
grab I can't rule with that so
naturally I'm just skeptical about it no
one walks on water Peter Jackson might
be making a mistake but only time and
seeing the movies will tell if they'll
just speculation at this point
nonetheless speculation is kind of what
I deal in when I do stuff like this so
the Hobbit being a trilogy what do you
think about that comment below let me
know and as always if you like what you
see here and you want to see more click
right here to see more